cette causerie a été enrichissante u13
intéressante d'ailleurs et je ne
s'appelait pas à ça je suis venu pour
s'exciter à chaque nouvelle comme
d'habitude mais ils ont appris des
choses il appelait mon noël d'où ça
vient
ils ont appris le mot avant pourquoi
l'avant qui venait après adventices
tories arrivés quatre dimanche à bonal
de suzuka
ils ont appuyé les ritournelles ils ont
apprécié des colos bretons et normands
qui avait apporté la tradition ici plus
les esclaves ils ont appliqué des femmes
des esclaves chanter dans des cases et
que les hommes sur canal et cher et les
ritournelles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
oh
que
vraiment contente de voir que les gens l
engouement que mon grand-père le loup a
entraîné que les choses devaient
continuer aujourd'hui même 18 ans après
son départ
malgré le fait qu'il nous a quittés bien
que voilà que les choses qu'il a mis en
place sont toujours présentes voilà je
suis vraiment contente que les gens se
réunissent sur ton corps autour des
chantiers noël
m
il
[Musique]
moi
non
et
oici
que de souvenirs aussi cette magie de
noël gonna do des jeunes se sont perdus
de vue depuis des années se retrouva
sont regardants et se met à chanter en
tendant les bras d'honneur à de l'autre
c'est ça nous rêve aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
à
les gens sont contents ils sérieux et
moi-même d'un modèle venu parler après
pour eux de venir dit effectivement on
appartient c'est tout ce que je dis là
je ne sais pas si c'est un écart de 50
ans il a appris des choses et je suis
fier voilà